Hey Anthony how was your weekend?
>> It was ok.
I was visiting a friend in
San Francisco, but I got kind of lost.
>> Did you ever find your friend?
>> Eventually.
It kind of took a while.
>> I hate getting lost, but it's always
nice when you can find your way.
>> Yeah it's sort of
like learning to code.
I remember learning my first language
and not really knowing what to do next.
>> And that's why you're here.
The purpose of this course is to help
you in your journey as a new programmer.
And to show you some different paths
you can take within the world of
programming.
I'm Georgia and i'm a course
developer here at you Udacity.
I'll be your guide as you
navigate this course.
>> And I'm Anthony and
I'm the course manager.
We'll be sharing some common experiences
that many new programmers have.
>> Let's start with the different
paths you can take within the world
of programming.